Jimmy Butler in the interview here's
what he says well first of all we would
have won if I would have played a better
game
we would have won if I would have played
a better game there's something so
attractive about a guy with that kind of
a mindset that is a very very attractive
mindset Michael had it Kobe had it I'm a
die-hard Laker fan I'm not rooting for
the Lakers simply because the guy that's
there right now it's just he posted a
story today on Instagram talking about
you guys will remember it but I don't
even know why you don't have me at my
number one wait till I leave the game
then you'll realize who says stuff like
that it's just that's not that's that's
somebody that needs attention how much
more attention do you need you're LeBron
James you don't need to be about
something like that just not attractive
it's a weak quality of a leader